>> HOSSAIN: Hello, everybody. My name is Monsur
Hossain. I work for the Google Data API's
team...
>> BIDELMAN: And I'm Eric Bidelman and I also
work for the Google Data API's team.
>> HOSSAIN: And we're here to talk to you
today by using the Google Data APIs and OAuth
to create an open social gadget. If you guys
have any questions, feel free to visit this
URL we have right here. You can go ahead and
post your questions on the Google moderator
site, and we'll take a look at them once the
session is over. You can also, you know, feel
free to ask questions up to the mic once the
presentation is over as well. Okay. So, our
goal today is to build an iGoogle gadget that
can read and write user data. So, just by
a show of hands here, how many people are
familiar with gadget development? Okay, a
good number. What about the Google Data APIs?
And, how about OAuth? Okay, great. Sounds
like a lot of you from Google gadget, that's
good because we're not going to cover as much
gadget development. We're going to focus more
on the aspects of using OAuth and using the
Google Data APIs when building a gadget. Kind
of like, what we're trying to do here is imagine
you have gadget living on iGoogle that's going
to want to load data from bloggers, so we're
going to talk about how we're actually going
to go about grabbing that data from blogger
and also writing data back to blogger. A lot
of the, a lot of the topics that you're going
to learn today, you can also apply it to other
open social containers and other services
that support OAuth, but for the purpose of
this talk, we're going to focus on iGoogle
and on Google services. So, some of the issues
you're going to run into is that traditional
JavaScript development practices are kind
of inadequate for what we want them to do.
You have issues such as cross-domain communication
is really hard to do, we're going to want
to load data from blogger to iGoogle and it's
really hard to talk cross-domain without doing
some sort of Iframe hack. Also, even you could
talk cross-domain, you can have issues with
the data format. Google data offers the JSON-in-script
format. If you're not familiar with JSON-in-script,
basically, what it does is you call JSON-in-script
with a callback function and it's going to
load some JSON onto your page and it's going
to call the callback with that JSON object.
This works really well for reading data, but
you can't write data back to the server using
this method. Even if there was a good way
to do, to write, you need a way to do authentication.
The Google Data APIs offer AuthSub and they
offer ClientLogin but this authentication
recommendation don't offer as great an experience
when being used in a gadget environment. So,
what we're going to is we're going to use
a Google Data JavaScript client with the OAuth
Proxy to create this gadget. So, the authentication
will be handled by OAuth while the Google
Data JavaScript client will handle the reading
and the writing of the data. So, just to give
you an idea of the technology stack that we're
dealing with--on the browser side, on the
client side, you're going to have your actual
gadget code which is going to talk to the
Google Data JavaScript client which in turn
is going to interface with the open social
JavaScript API specifically gadgets.io.makerequest.
This is all going to be sent up to the iGoogle
server where it'll be received by the iGoogle
server and also processed by the OAuth Proxy
to handle the OAuth portion. And finally,
that request is going to be sent off to the
service provider which in this case will be
a blogger or if you're using any other Google
service, calendar, context, you know whatever.
So, I kind of made sense of the entire technology
stack we've been talking about today. Okay.
So, I'm going to start by giving a little
bit of background into what OAuth is and how
it's used in a gadget environment. So, OAuth
is an open standard for sharing user's private
data with another website or a gadget. When
using OAuth, it eliminates the need to have
to share passwords between sites. So if you're
in iGoogle, I don't have to give my password
to iGoogle who in turn gives it off to another
site. Instead, what happens is that, I get
a token and this token is used to make all
authenticated requests. All data requests
are digitally signed, so if you're familiar
with AuthSub's secure mode is very similar
to that. So, to give a little background by
how OAuth works, we're going to start first
by looking at the players in this OAuth dance.
So first of all, there's the actual user of
the gadget which would be you yourself or
anyone else sitting in front of the computer.
Next, comes the consumer. The consumer is
the application that's trying to access the
user's data. In our particular case, the consumer
is going to be iGoogle who's going to be requesting
the data on behalf of the gadget. Lastly,
you have the service provider. The service
provider is going to be the keeper of the
user's data. In this particular case, it's
going to be blogger or any other Google service.
So, these three OAuth players are going to
interact in three distinct steps which is
called the OAuth process or the OAuth dance.
So this first, the first step is a get request
token step. This is a behind-the-scenes request
from the consumer to the service provider;
the user doesn't see any of this. What's going
to happen is that the consumer is going ask
the service provider for a request token and
this request token is going to be used in
some screen request between, in the OAuth
process. So after obtaining that initial request
token, the consumer is going to redirect the
user over to the service provider. So, once
he uses that service provider site, say once
the user's at the Google site, if he hasn't
logged in today, if he hasn't logged in yet,
he's going to be asked to log in and then
he's going to be asked to authorize the request
token. And what that basically means is that
he's going to see a site that says, hey, you
know, iGoogle wants to access your data, do
you want to give them permission to use your
data? And, the user can say yes or no. So,
we're going to assume, of course, that the
user says yes. So, what's going to happen?
As the user clicks authorize and then the
user is redirected back to the consumer site.
Now when the consumer sees that the users
arrive at their site, we have the third step
which is called the "get access token" step.
And this is another behind-the-scenes request
from the consumer to the service provider.
So, what happens is the consumer says, hey,
you know I got this authorize request token.
It shows it to a service provider, the service
provider says, yes, the user has authorized
you to load data, and then, it returns back
this access token. So this access token is
going to be used at all subsequent requests
in order to load data from the Google servers.
So, that's kind of the OAuth process in a
nutshell. However, the OAuth process has some
issues when being used in JavaScript. First
you got this issue of crypto. I mean, you
could do it JavaScript but you users are always
going to be or some malicious user is always
going to be able to hit, you know, Control
U or Command U. They're going to be able to
view the source, and at some level, you're
always worried that the user can get at, you
know, your crypto secrets, so there really
are no secrets when using JavaScript. The
next issue as I mentioned earlier is cross-domain.
As you saw the OAuth process has a lot of
communications between the consumer and the
service provider and you're going to have
a hard time doing that when you're using JavaScript.
And lastly, you have the question of storage.
You've got all these tokens going back and
forth, and where do you store these tokens
when you receive them? You know, do you put
them in cookies, or what's the standard way
to do that? So, in order to address all these
issues in JavaScript, we have the OAuth Proxy.
The OAuth Proxy is, it lives in the iGoogle
server. It's an open source. It goes under
the name of shindig, if you're familiar with
the open source project and basically, what
the OAuth Proxy does is it manages the OAuth
dance for gadget. So now with the issue of
crypto, we don't have to worry about that
because the OAuth Proxy signs a request on
behalf of the gadget. We don't have to worry
about cross-domain issues because the OAuth
Proxy lives on the same server as the gadget.
So the gadget can just use HTML repeated requests
to talk back to your OAuth Proxy. And lastly,
we don't have to worry about storage because
the OAuth Proxy is going to manage all the
token information for the gadget. So, if you
revisit again the three steps of the OAuth
process that I've mentioned earlier, you'll
see that the OAuth Proxy is going to handle
the request token step and the access token
step for you. As a gadget developer, you'll
mostly be concerned with redirecting the user
in order to authorize the request token.
>> The OAuth process lives on the what?
>> HOSSAIN: It lives on the server. So, this
kind of, here's a general skeleton outline
of the gadget module prefs section. You'll
see, we've added, now, we're going to talk
about kind of how to enable OAuth in a gadget
environment, so we've got the module prefs
section. We're going to add a section called
OAuth and we're going to add to that a section
named service with the name attribute set
to Google which indicates that we're going
to be talking to a Google server. Next, we're
going to go ahead and add a specific URL for
each of the three steps of the OAuth process.
Of course, we have the request URL. This right
here, the Google.com/accounts/OAuthGetRequestToken
is standard for doing OAuth against any Google
server. Have you noticed here the scope parameter?
What the scope parameter says is that it indicates
which service your gadget wants to talk to.
In this particular case, the scope is sent
to blogger because you want to talk to, we
want to get data from the blogger service.
Next, we're going to add the authorization
section and this is basically the URL that
the user should visit in order to authenticate
or authorize with Google. Notice here, we've
got the OAuth callback parameter. Basically,
when the user is redirected to the authorization
URL, they're going to authenticate, they're
going to authorize, but once they've finished
all that step, all those steps, the service
provider needs to know where to send to the
user back on the consumer side. So, the service
provider is going to send them back to this
OAuth callback URL. Lastly, we've got the
access token step. This is, this tells the
iGoogle server where to visit on the service
provider in order to exchange the request
token for an access token. So here's what
the entire module prefs section looks like
and basically, with these three URLs, we've
laid down the groundwork of doing OAuth in
your gadget. Next, Eric is going to come up
and talk to you about actually building the
gadget.
>> BIDELMAN: All right, thanks, Mon. Thank
you, Monsur. So, Monsur sure laid the groundwork
on our setup, on our setup code for gadget,
what we need to do to use the OAuth proxy
to talk to one of the Google Data APIs. Now,
we're going to take a look at some code, we're
going take a look at both, you know, the JavaScript
required to pull and push data to blogger
and also the presentation where what you sort
of need to do to manage these different states.
This request token state--this authorization
where the users throw in to Google and then
the Access token state. So, we'll do that
both in OpenSocial using some of the OpenSocial
APIs and we'll do that using the Google data
JavaScript client lateral, take a look at
different ways, I can answer your question
real quick.
>> [INDISTINCT]?
>> BIDELMAN: It's on the server, it's iGoogle
server, so the question was where does OAuth
proxy live? That's iGoogle. So, we define
the mod prefs section, you know, on the previous
couple of slides, we'd sold the OAuth endpoints
there, in that OAuth tag. And now, we're just
requiring the OpenSocial APIs and then there's
a special feature here, this OAuth pop up
feature and we'll talk about that, that's
actually, that'll provide a great user experience
for users. This is a pop up window that's
going to show the user that they want to access
their blogger data and then subsequently when
the gadget tries to fetch data when that pop
up window closes, that features completely
required in here. And, lastly, there's just
you know the regular content section, and
that's where you're going to be putting, you
know, presentations, CSS and possible JavaScript
so, let's dive into that. So here's sort of
the overall picture of what needs to happen
and we'll take a look at each of these sections.
You can see it's, you know, relatively few
lines of HTML code to get all this working.
So, the first thing you need to do is sort
of add this unauthenticated state and we're
doing this with different div containers.
You'll notice that, initially we're not displaying
any of these, and that's because the gadgets
going to have these different states and we'll
take a look at the code behind that in a second.
Look, the approval state is your authenticated
state. So when the gadget installed for the
first time the user visits your gadget, or
there are iGoogle pictures for the first time
the gadget is installed, they're going to
need to authenticate that, and actually obtain
this request token and then go through this
OAuth dance like Monsur talked about. So in
this case we're just displaying, you know,
sign in to blogger, we'll fill this href with
a response that we'll get from the OAuth Proxy
and we'll take a look of that code. Next is
to serve this pending state right you're waiting
for the user to go through the approval and
actually grant access to your data. So, in
this case, we're just displaying a link that
says "I've approved access." A user shouldn't
actually see this if you're using that OAuth
pop up feature, what we just saw because a
gadget will always try to refresh itself,
and they'll never actually see this. So, the
pop will go away and that'll be taken care
for you but, if you don't use the pop up,
you know, you can do something like this and
just have the URL and fill it as needed. Next
is sort of authenticated stage, just the sort
of the normal operating state of the gadgets
so the user already has approved access to
their data and then, in this case, we'll just
fill it with data, you know, reference its
I.D. and fill it with data once we're authenticated.
A couple nice to haves, you know, if anything
goes wrong maybe the user denies access to
the data, maybe you show a meaningful message
and some kind of errors div with a big red
text or something. Another nice to have, you
know, display something that the user, I am
loading data, these gadgets are trying to
fetch data, I'm trying to post data, you know
maybe an Ajax loader and gift and some text
there. So, let's see some practice, there's
actually the Google Data JavaScript client
library is, is a read/write library for web
applications and we'll take a look at this
blogger gadget real quick. So, you can see,
I have this pretty boring blog that I started.
I have one post, it's not very interesting,
but it was started yesterday so bear with
me. And we'll install this blogger gadget
and you can see we have that sign at the blog
URL, and if I'll just refresh the page, you
know, as the gadget will try to, it'll try
to fetch data for the first time, it uses
unauthenticated this point, there's no request
token associated with the gadget. So, we fill
the href with the response we got from OAuth
proxy. Here's that pop up window feature that
I was talking about and you can see that I've
approved access link this pending state. So,
I do trust this gadget with my blogger data,
so I'm going to grant access; we'll be redirected
back to the OAuth callback URL. If you use
the OAuth callback URL that was in a few slides
back, that actually just closes the window
using some JavaScript and the gadget is smart
enough to know to refresh itself; and we'll
take a look at what exactly went behind that.
But, you can see there's a road to be painless
experience for the user, you know, one pop
up, one click, a few clicks to grant access
and now the gadget is in its authenticated
state, I mean, let me maximize this for you,
guys. So
you can see the gadget refreshed itself but
I have a token, so this is the normal state,
right? And, it's kind of a nifty gadget I
can choose which blog I want to post to you.
I can say Google I/O. It can tag this, you
can publish that to blogger. So if all goes
well, we should see my new post show up in
blogger and there you go. So, we read data,
we read data from blogger, we got the list
of blogs and then we posted a new entry to
blogger. So, how did we do that? [pause] By
the way, this code is an open source at this
URL if you're interested, it's blogger_gadget.
So, how do we load data? For those familiar
with the OpenSocial APIs, there's a gadgets
I/O make request. And what's going on with
actually--inside the Google data library is
we're wrapping that function with some of
the open methods. And you just pass the URL,
the feed you're interested in. You pass a
callback function to process the results,
the JSON results you get from the response,
and then you pass us an optional parameters
of JSON object. In this case, the OAuth Proxy
and the iGoogle, you're going to actually
need those parameters because we need to tell
the OAuth Proxy that we're using OAuth, you
need to tell them that we're using tokens.
We'll take a look what's required. And again,
the OAuth Proxy is handling all of this cryptography
work for us. All you do is, you know, write
your OpenSocial calls using make request,
or using the help library functions and this
works which is great because we like that.
So OpenSocial, what does this look like in
JavaScript? Pretty simple right? So, the first
time the gadget loads, you're going to have
to register on load handler and then we're
just going to call some kind of initialization
function. In this case we're just fetching
data. So, the magic here is we're fetching
data. Let's take a closer look at that. Here's
the overall picture I just want to show you.
You know, it's one slide of a code but, it's
powerful, right? I'm using the same function
in the blogger gadget to post data to blogger
and also read data so, take a look at each
section a little more closely. You saw in
the example, the first time the gadget loads,
we're just showing the animation, you know,
presenting the user with some kind of meaningful
representation that we're doing something
in the background. We're setting up a callback
function. This callback function is going
to process the response JSON from the OAuth
Proxy and the iGoogle server. The first time
the gadget loads and it's unauthenticated,
you're going to get the response object and
there's going to be this OAuth approval URL
inside that object. And so that's the sign
in to blogger link right there. That's actually
the URL that we used to fill that href. So,
if we have that, we know to use, we know what
state the gadget's in. So we're going to create
a pop up handler and we'll take a look at
that, and just pass that to URL that we want
the user to go to. That's the, excuse me,
the OAuth approval URL. And then, we're just
going to show the approval state waiting for
the users to make that action. So, if we're
now actually authenticating and the user has
gone through this process, we'll use the same
fetch data function and we'll try to fetch
data again. This time, we may have a feed
object. So, in the case, the Google data APIs
is going to have feed object with a bunch
of entries, you know, each entry being a blog,
a post, or a comment or, you know what have
you. All right, we're just going to show those
results in that main div there. Well, to be
straightforward there, otherwise, there might
be an error, maybe, you know, the user denied
access again. Maybe there's something wrong
with our request so we'll just show them,
you know, some kind of meaningful error and
show the errors div. To continue on with the
same codes as we had, in the previous slide,
this is the important section here, this is
where we setup the I/O request parameters.
So, we're talking to Google, our OAuth service
name will be Google. Our method, we'll do
a "get method" to get the list of blogs. Our
content type they're expecting will be JSON
from the server. Yes?
>> Is the post supported?
>> BIDELMAN: Post is supported, yes. That's
how we did the post the blogger, so, well,
take a look at in a second. The authorization
type is OAuth, of course, using the OAuth
Proxy, and we're always going to be using
tokens. So, this gadget is accessing private
data and also writing data as you're going
to need to be authenticated. And the last
thing you want to do is just make that, hit
that endpoint that you want to talk to. So
we're getting a list of blogs and then we're
requesting the results in JSON and then making
the request with the callback we set up here
and then the params that we setup here.
So, the pop up handler, the thing that makes
us all work, so we saw the sign in the blogger
link that was the first thing when the gadget
is being authenticated, we're passing OAuth
approval URL in there. We're creating an OnClick
handler for that link, or an open function,
it's just going to open that pop up or show
the waiting state. The user will click grant
access, the gadget will refresh itself. The
CloseHandler will be invoked, we'll show the
loading state, we'll try to fetch data for
the first time, and this is a sort of the
setup code to make all that happen. You can
see that now the gadgets fetch data to an
authenticated state, and so you're just passing
in a hide, you're passing in a whip for that
pop up URL and the two handlers there. So
I promise we'd make things a little easier.
Like I said, we have a JavaScript client library
that's sort of, you know, takes care of, at
least if you're talking to the Google Data
APIs, has a lot of helpful functionality.
It can be used for reading and writing data.
It doesn't have to be used in OAuth Proxy
or iGoogle, this can be used in a web application
using JavaScript, so we have a special AuthSub
JS for the JavaScript library. It uses cross-domain
and communications and using some Iframe frame
magic. And what we do is we just wrap the
gadgets I/O make request. So, you can take
advantage of the libraries helper methods
without having to worry about in the OpenSocial
APIs and there's more information at JS-client,
that URL there. So, we have the same sort
of setup code we had in the OpenSocial world,
you know, we have the unregistered handler
for when the gadget first loads, we're calling
some kind of a knit function, but now, we
have a little more setup to do. What you want
to do is you want to load the Google Data
library, so you can include the same common
loader that's used in the Maps API, the Earth
API, you know, the AJAX libraries, and so
we'll load that using the google.load. We'll
load the gdata module and then, we'll specify,
optionally specify packages. In this case,
this example right here, we'll talk to blogger
encounter. You can minimize some overhead
by requesting certain packages, you can request
the whole library, you can do whatever you
want depending on what your gadget needs,
your WebAPP needs. So, we'll set an unload
callback for when the library loads. We're
talking to bloggers, so we'll setup a blogger
service object and it'll pass the name of
our application, it just takes the form of
your company name, the name of your gadget
in a sort of a version number. Probably, the
most important line on this slide if you take
anything away from the slide is this one,
this is saying "Yes, library I'm going to
be in the OAuth Proxy, we're going to be using
Google as our service provider." Oops, oops,
oops, oops. And then the last thing we do
is we fetch data like we did in the OpenSocial
case. So, you can see there's a little more
setup code, but you'll save some, in the next
slide, you'll see the benefits of this library.
The last thing you can do, if you're in a
Google Apps domain, you can optionally set
the HT parameter to your domain, and that'll
provide a more smooth lined user experience
when the user logs in. They won't have to
choose which accounts to log in, they'll just
get your Google Apps log-in instead. Okay.
So with the same fetch data we had in OpenSocial,
you know, we're showing the divs, we're having
the same callback function to create the OAuth
approval URL on the pop up. We had the gadgets
I/O request parameters before in OpenSocial;
you can actually just get rid of all those.
And instead just make the call directly to
the feed we're talking to, the feeds, default
blogs, we're getting the list of blogs. You
notice we're not appending the ALT JSON anymore
because by default, the library uses JSON.
So you just can hit that endpoint directly
and then instead of calling gadgets I/O make
request, you can just use one of library's
helper functions so, you know, get the blog
feed in this case, and we're passing it to
URL. It's important to know that the callback
that will process the results from the server
and the error handler is the same callback
because we're trying to, we're fetching data
when the gadget loads and also when they're
come back from the approval page. So we're
going to use the same URL to do both, sorry,
excuse me, the same function to, to do both.
So creating data, as I said the library can
be used to read and write data using JavaScript,
so in that blogger example, what I did was
I added just a post data method. Right, we're
passing a blog that we want to post to and
then we're just setting up a new entry, in
this case gdata blogger BlogPostEntry and
it's just JSON, so we're setting a title,
you know, we're setting a content, a couple
of categories maybe for labels and optionally,
if you want to mark that blogger entry that
new post as a draft or not. So we referenced
that new library, in the blogger insert entry
function, the link we'll post to is the blog's
edit link, the entry post link and then, we'll
reference that new entry that we just created
out here and we'll have a handle insert method
and the HandleError method, those are on the
next slide. So just for your reference, this
is how we actually got this red blog here.
We just did, remember the get blog feed with
the blog list URL. We process that response
from the server and just posted to that the
first entry we found, the first entry being
the first blog.
So a little cleaner, a little cleaner than
the OpenSocial world, if you're using Google
Data APIs, this code would be much more verbose
if you're using OpenSocial, obviously you
can't take advantage of the library's functions,
if you're not using the library and the library
does the JSON XML to Atom XML back to JSON
for you. We'll do questions then. The handle
insert and handle error methods both pretty
simple, right? We're just, just displaying
the link to the blog we posted to the user.
This is the entry that was posted, you'll
get that in the response from the server,
and the HTML link is the actual link to the
blogs, if you visit, in the website that would
be the same URL there. The HandleError method
is just presenting, you know, a meaningful
alert message, the user is saying something,
something went wrong or the server doesn't
understand your entry or what not. So, I think
I'm going to hand it back to Monsur now who's
going to talk a little bit more what's going
on behind-the-scenes and how all of these
OAuth Proxy magic is happening, let's hear
it.
>> HOSSAIN: All right, thanks Eric. So, it's
all a little bit about how to setup your gadget.
Now we're going to talk about what's going
on behind-the-scenes. So, excuse me, we have
this, this single line from the JavaScript
Client basically with the URL, and we have
our two handlers in our particular example,
the handlers are the same but they could also
be different because there's success handler
and error handler. And then, basically, these
are going to get wrapped up and it's going
to call gadgets.io.makerequest like we saw
earlier, so, here we have the gadgets.io.makerequest
call. Notice some modified callback here gadgets.io.makerequest
only accepts one callback. So, what the Google
Data JavaScript client does is that it takes
those that success callback and that error
callback and wraps it into one and then it
just batches it accordingly whether it gets
a successful result or an error result. Also
notice we have the OAuth parameters here which
Eric also showed us earlier. So that also
gets filled in for you because the JavaScript
client understands, for example, whether or
not it's doing a get or a post, and all of
the rest of the variables are pretty much
the same. So, what happens is this gadgets.io.makerequest
is going to end up making an XML, HTTP request
back to the iGoogle server. So that XML HTTP
request is always going to be a post, and
that's just the way that to make request call
works. Notice here gmodules.com domain which
is basically the same domain that the gadget
lives on. Within this post, you're going to
have a couple of items in the body of the
request, for example, you have the URL which
is going to be the URL you want to make the
request to. You've got the original HTTP method
and you post data that goes along with it
and so on and so forth. So, basically, when
the iGoogle server, this is all going to go
to the iGoogle server; whenever we see this
request, it's going to basically unwind the
request and say "Okay, this is a request that
needs to go to blogger.com, it needs to be
a get request and so on" and it's actually
going to make this request to blogger. When
blogger gets his request, it has one of two
possible responses, it could say "Oh, you
know, I've got the OAuth token here, everything's
in good shape, here's the blogger data for
the user." However, if the user isn't logged
in using OAuth, then blogger server is going
to say "Hey, wait a minute, this user doesn't
have permission yet, and it's going to send
back a failure response. And that failure
response looks something like this, so it's
going to be a JSON object and all of the request,
other responses back to gadgets.io.makerequest,
are going to be JSON objects. However, notice
that the body of this response is empty and
instead of a body, we have this OAuth approval
URL here, and the OAuth approval URL is going
to be the same URL that we saw in step two
of the OAuth process, and it's going to be
the, the pop up that the gadgets are going
to show in order for the user to authorize
with. So, new gadgets are just going to see
this OAuth approval URL and as Eric's code
showed earlier, it's going to show the pop
up accordingly. So, once the user, you know,
authenticates, authorizes, the gadgets are
going to try to make the request again. And
this time since the user is properly authorized,
they're going to get back a successful response
from the blogger server, and a successful
response is going to look something like this.
You still have the JSON object but in the
body field, you actually have the JSON of
the blogger response, so that's going to have
your feeds and your entries and all that kind
of stuff. And so, that's kind of a sense what's
going on behind-the-scenes and Eric's going
to talk about a few more demos.
>> BIDELMAN: So, we saw blogger gadget but
there's, you know, 14, 15, 16 Google Data
APIs now, analytics and, and the Maps Data
API being the, the latest additions. So we
can talk to any of these APIs using or any,
any as mentioned by Monsur, any OAuth service
provider for that matter using OpenSocial.
So there's a base example we can show and
there's also a calendar gadget we can show.
[pause] So, this is an example for counter,
you know, I've used the same sort of logic
and setup code, my contents, my divs and then
the sign of the calendar link using the same
creep pop up handler. This time, we're accessing
the calendar scope in that OAuth request URL
instead of the bloggers scope. We'll grant
access and it's a very interesting gadget,
it just gives a list of these test accounts,
list of calendars. But, it's literally the,
you know, the same idea for any of these APIs
using the JavaScript client library. I think
I wrote this in probably five minutes as I
pored it over the blogger gadget, so just
showing you how easy it is and how versatile
it is. Another example using Google Base,
and you'll notice, I didn't have to approve
access to this one because Google Base actually
has public feeds. This does use the JavaScript
client library but I didn't have to go through
the OAuth dance, so this is another sort of
example of things you can do. This gadget
uses settings on, I'm searching for software
job titles around the mountain view area,
you know, there are 75,000 and above. So,
if I save that settings, we'll get some results
and each of these is just one of the entries
based that somebody posted, and there's pagination
in the Google Data feeds so you can paginate
to these results. So, you can provide some
pretty powerful gadgets using the library
in little or no time, and both of those are
open source, those two URLs there if you're
interested in the source code. All right,
to wrap things up, we saw a lot of technology
there. We, you know, introduced OAuth, we
talked about a little bit about OAuth and
the basics behind it. We talked about OpenSocial,
how to set up a gadget to use the OAuth Proxy
in iGoogle, we talked about the Google Data
APIs and then we saw the same sort of JavaScript
to talk to Google Data APIs using the JavaScript
client library. We talked about how OAuth
Proxy, Monsur talked about how the OAuth Proxy
handles theses requests for us and we don't
have to worry about any crypto, you know,
token management, whatsoever. We just literally
call the APIs, we post data, you know, we
update data, we delete data from the APIs
and then we talked about the server side of
things a little bit. So, as always, we have
a great list of resources for you, there's
information on the JavaScript client library
and how you can use that within a WebAPP or,
you know, the OAuth Proxy in iGoogle and the
gadget space. There's a comprehensive article
on writing OAuth gadgets, this is all sort
of the OAuth goodness and OAuth Proxy goodness
in that article there, and there's code samples.
There's example gadgets, there's example WebAPPs
so you can get quickly started with--in the
different APIs, if you're interested. All
right. So, I think we have a Google moderator
link and, again, it's I/O OAuth gadgets. If
you would like to ask questions on moderator,
feel free to also step to the mic so we can,
sorry, so we can hear you too on the video
and we'll also be available afterwards if
you want to come up and talk to us. Thank
you.
>> Thank you for a great presentation.
>> BIDELMAN: Thank you.
>> It's a several part question. We saw the
ability to post and also read the comments
of a blog, how about drilling into, searching
into that blog on a particular discussion
thread and reading from within that discussion
thread or posting to inside that discussion
thread, is it just generally to a blog, is
that their ability? And, the second part,
second question is how does OAuth integrate
given the fact that for instance, for enterprises,
we have our own [INDISTINCT] or internal LTAP.
Do we now, does it integrate, given that OAuth
is hosted by iGoogle and how? And, or do we
now have to create two different users accounts
onto separate systems separated from each
other?
>> BIDELMAN: All right, I can answer your
first one because I remember that one. So,
you can do using OAuth and three legged OAuth
as we saw in this, the examples, you can do
anything the APIs can do. So, in the case
of blogger, yes, you can, you know, post comments,
you can retrieve the comments. Each blog has
a comments feed that you can use to get that
and then post and update comments and what
not, and same thing with the other APIs. So,
anything you can do in the APIs using your
server, you can do using OAuth and the OAuth
Proxy.
>> So, that means that you have search capability
within the blog? So, for instance, you can
key on for certain words, you can sort that
and you can display in a certain form? Is
that built in to the protocol or is that something
that you have to handle in your code?
>> HOSSAIN: Yes, so, it's probably something
you have to handle in your code. I mean, the
APIs expose underlying functionality that
blogger itself exposes, so I mean, there isn't
really a way to do that. I mean, you need
basically to grab the entries yourself and
then add that capability on it yourself.
>> BIDELMAN: So, yeah, I just add that each
of the API is, you know, its own query model
that the Google data protocol has a standard
set of protocol parameters that you can use,
search full text and title, search on title
and full text. I'm not sure what blogger actually
supports if they support full text search
on, you know, the body of the contents of
this other blog.
>> Other blog like gquery support or anything
like that?
>> BIDELMAN: No.
>> No? Okay.
>> BIDELMAN: No. They're protocol.
>> HOSSAIN: And for your second question.
So, within your file URL, are you yourself
running the iGoogle server or the OpenSocial
server, see, if you're hosting it all internally
then you'd be able to configure the OAuth
Proxy yourself and
>> So, if we were to host it internally, then,
does it have an interface to A.D.? Does it
have an interface to LTAP where it can actually
go and ask for credentials from that system
and pull them in to URL, or do we still have
to enter into two separate xylo systems?
>> HOSSAIN: Yeah, I don't believe the, that
sort of capability is there right now. So,
yeah, users will have to authenticate with
OAuth as long as, as a separate kind of interaction
with the gadget.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> I'm interested in the third party servers
that you have for the OAuth. Do you have an
estimate as to what percentage of the gadgets
that you have are powered by third party servers
or is it mostly Google stuff?
>> HOSSAIN: Do you mean the gadgets in general
like service providers, OAuth Providers?
>> Exactly. OAuth Service Poviders.
>> BIDELMAN: No idea the stats up on top of
my head but I know for a fact that, you know,
I've created a number of different OAuth service
provider, gadget, MySpace, you know, Netflix
has an OAuth, API, Twitter has an OAuth API,
and you can, what you can do is you can register,
actually on that article explains the writing
OAuth gadgets article explains how to register
a gadget that doesn't talk to Google. So,
if you're talking let's say MySpace, you know,
you register your consumer key and consumer
seeker with us, I think it's just an email
and then, so then you can use the, one of
their APIs, their OAuth endpoints instead
of Google's. Does that answer your question?
>> Yes, it does. What if I wanted to implement
my own OAuth server? Is there a service that
I can go to, to help me do that or do I have
to set up my server that does the implementation?
I mean, you mentioned MySpace and Twitter
>> BIDELMAN: Yeah, if you wanted to actually
issue tokens and be a service provider?
>> Yes, yes.
>> BIDELMAN: As far as, I think there's a
few, maybe, OpenSocial projects that use AppEngine
to do that and maybe you can look at that
code.
>> HOSSAIN: You can also, you go to oauth.net,
you could, there's a bunch OpenSocial libraries
that you could use depending on what language
you're programming in. And I think most of
them handle both server and client side of
doing OAuth.
>> So, it really want to, all I want to do
is give users of my gadget access to their
data that stored of my server using OAuth
as opposed to on Blogger or My Space.
>> HOSSAIN: Right.
>> BIDELMAN: Definitely. Yeah, like Monsur
said those libraries have server code as well
as client code so. Show the monitor. Where
can we find guidance for integrating GData
APIs into non-web clients, eg.netapps on windows?
>> HOSSAIN: So, if you go to the main, what's
the link again? If you go to the main iGoogle
Data APIs site, its code., oops, code.google.com/api/gdata,
under the "Docs" section, and right here,
on the left hand side, there's a "Client Libraries"
link. This will kind of give you an idea of
all the client libraries that are available
under GData so its Java.net, JavaScript, PHP,
Python, Objective-C, so we kind of got a sense
of all the libraries we provide right there
so that's a good place to start and the documentations,
samples and reference guides for all in Client
Libraries.
>> BIDELMAN: Okay.
>> HOSSAIN: Is there any other questions?
Okay, we're good.
>> BIDELMAN: All right, well, thank you. We
know this is the last session of the day.
Thanks for coming.
>> HOSSAIN: Thank you.